the uncertainty principle thing called
the casimir effect and hopefully a
little bit about black holes as well
so i guess we have to start with the
basic physics which is the uncertainty
principle it's this weird thing that you
can't measure the position and the
momentum of a particle at the same time
and actually for this video the
important one is you can't measure the
time of something and the energy of
something at exactly the same time so if
you want you've got a photon you can
measure exactly when it arrives if you
want but then you don't know what its
energy is or you can measure exactly
what its energy is but then you don't
know what exactly what time it arrives
and there's a fundamental uncertainty in
that energy which works even if the
photon has zero energy so if the photon
fundamentally has zero energy then
there's an uncertainty that actually
you you can't tell whether it's zero
energy it could actually have some
energy so that means a photon with zero
energy isn't there at all basically
you've got nothing there and that means
that instead even when there's nothing
there you can actually have a photon
with a suddenly acquiring an energy and
that leads to this weird effect that
even in the vacuum of space you can have
photons popping into existence for a
brief period of time so basically you
can sort of cheat nature you can borrow
energy as long as you put it back before
anyone notices and that's this trade-off
between the amount of energy you've got
and the amount of time you've got and
the more energy you borrow the less time
you can borrow it for and that means
that the vacuum of space is actually
deceiving mass of particles and
anti-particles being created there are
some rules so that you have to kind of
create particles in pairs but beyond
that
even in the vacuum of space you can have
particles popping into existence and
disappearing again so this idea that
vacuum is empty is kind of it's actually
not correct right that even in vacuum
you have these virtual particles that
appear and disappear so it applies to
every particle
absolutely anything you know so i was
talking initially about photons but you
can do it with electrons and positrons
appearing you can have protons and
antiprotons you can have anything you
want but obviously the more massive the
particle is remember from einstein's
famous equation e equals m c squared the
more massive the particle is the more
energy you're borrowing to create it and
therefore the quicker you have to put it
back before anyone notices so the least
massive particles can exist for the
longest periods of time couldn't create
like a planet or a gold nugget these are
in principle you could create anything
but of course by the time you get up to
what on the cosmic scale of things that
they're very large masses then they
disappear on such a short time scale
that really that you know they
effectively don't exist it sounds like
it's made up but actually there are
experimental tests you can do to show
that a vacuum is actually a seething
mass of particles it's not empty space
there is this famous experiment uh a
phenomenon thing called the casimir
effect that was predicted way back in
the 1940s that says that if you do an
experiment where you've got two plates
very very close together so about a
micron apart so 10 to the minus six
meters apart then actually what happens
well well you've got the seething mass
of photons being created out here by
this uncertainty principle and you've
actually got photons being created in
the gap between the two plates as well
but the interesting thing is because
you've now got this pair of plates that
actually restricts the kind of photons
that you can create you can't for
example create light with very long
wavelengths because it wouldn't fit into
that gap
so just by having a pair of plates
although this effect is still going on
you create fewer particles in the gap in
between than you do out here now the
photons out here bouncing around and
hitting the plate exert a pressure on it
and the photons in here bouncing around
that are being created by this virtual
effect create a pressure this side but
of course now we're creating less
photons in this gap which means there's
a bigger pressure this side than there
is on this side so there's actually a
force
and this force has now been measured
that you can actually detect this force
you set up this experiment
you can actually detect this force and
the plates actually get pushed together
by this effect called the casimir effect
where you're actually seeing this effect
of the the virtual photons being created
this seeding mass of virtual particles
but just more of them on one side of the
plate than the other it explains things
but the main thing it does is creates a
huge problem
because if you're a theoretical
physicist you can do a calculation that
says okay so i'm creating all these
virtual particles they've got mass
associated with them how much mass am i
actually creating in the universe that
just from this stuff popping into
existence
and the answer is unless you're very
careful how you do the calculation you
end up with an infinite mass
and so actually actually one of these
problems that that theoretical
physicists have that if you do the naive
calculation of just says well let's
let's let this effect go what's going to
happen and the answer is you end up with
a universe that just doesn't work
because you end up with infinite mass
density everywhere and the whole thing
you get infinities appearing in your
mathematics so theoretical physicists
have to do all these clever maths using
a process called renormalization which
basically is a way of kind of shoveling
all those infinities under a rug and not
worrying about them anymore i get the
impression this must be a very faint
phenomena because like for example when
a when a rocket ships going to the moon
it's not it's not running into a barrage
of particles that keep popping into its
path well it is but actually you're
right the impact it has on the rocket is
tiny because the forces involved are
very tiny and that's this effect of this
you know again if you just do a naive
calculation that says how big should
this effect be if you're not careful you
end up predicting it should be a huge
effect and somehow it ends up being
normalized down to this very small
effect but it is you're right it's a
pretty small effect in everyday life
okay you did promise me black hole okay
so we need to do another thing before we
get to black holes which is that's the
was the casimir effect now there's a
thing called the dynamical casimir
effect which says that okay so if i got
this pair of plates then this phenomenon
goes on and we have these virtual
particles being created out here and you
know on either side but there's fewer in
here and that's creates the force now
the dynamical kasami effect says that
actually if you think about the virtual
particles being created in here if i
accelerate one of the plates very
quickly
so instead of just having them sitting
next to each other i move it backwards
and forwards very quickly
some of those virtual particles become
real
so actually the things which are popping
in and out of existence some of them
actually become real particles and
there's two ways to think about this
either you can think about it of saying
that actually when you wrench them apart
these little pairs of particles which
pop into existence and then recombine
and disappear again they kind of lose
track of each other because they kind of
get pulled apart as well they lose their
twin they lose their twin um or
alternatively you want a duller
explanation you can say that actually
the interaction of the kind of the
electromagnetic field you're creating in
this space and the metal plate when you
accelerate it ends up creating photons
from the surface and the photons are
then emitted from the surface but either
way in some sense the energy that was
originally in those
virtual photons in the gap gets
converted into real photons and you
haven't cheated it seems like you're
getting energy for nothing now that you
know you haven't paid back the debt but
actually you have because in order to
accelerate this plate there's a force
remember and when you accelerate
something against the force you end up
doing work so actually just pulling the
plate backwards and forwards puts energy
into the system so you're not cheating
nature and for a long time that this was
thought to be kind of this was just a
thought experiment and the the trick is
the problem is from an experimental
point of view that actually you have to
move the plate at relativistic speeds so
the plate that you're moving backwards
and forwards has to move at some decent
fraction of the speed of light which you
just can't do with real plates but
actually just a couple of years ago
someone did a very subtle experiment
where they instead of having a pair of
plates and a gap in between they kind of
created an electronic analog of this
which is they had a waveguide which is
just something that that kind of forces
photons to travel in one dimension and
at one end of it they put one of these
things called a squid which is a
superconducting device where by changing
the properties of the squid you can
effectively change the length of the
waveguide at whatever speed you want so
they could actually drive it at like
about five percent of the speed of light
so get up to a speed where actually they
were effectively changing the gap this
this kind of cavity at those kinds of
speeds when they did that they found
that this cavity started emitting uh
microwave photons so actually the effect
has finally actually been detected in
2011 for the first time so that then
gets us on to black holes a black hole
obviously you know you haven't got
accelerations in a black hole but you've
got gravity and there's this thing in in
general relativity called the
equivalence principle that basically
says that the way gravity behaves is is
indistinguishable from the way that
acceleration behaves and actually
anyone who's ever stood in a lift is
familiar with this in that when it
starts going up when you start getting
accelerated upwards you feel heavier and
actually you've no way of knowing
whether the gravitational field unless
you can look out through the window
you've no way of knowing whether the
gravitational field of the earth has
increased which is why you feel heavier
or whether you're being accelerated
which is why you feel heavier so
everything that you know basically the
physics of acceleration and the physics
of gravity is very similar so in a in a
black hole you don't have accelerating
plates but you have gravity plenty of
gravity and exactly the same thing
happens close to the event horizon of a
black hole where you have this
gravitational field that basically the
virtual photons that are popping into
existence and disappearing around the
black hole lead to real photons being
produced now again you can think about
this two ways either you can say that
this interaction of the electromagnetic
field with the event horizon the black
hole makes the event horizon emit
photons or you can have the rather more
romantic picture that these pairs of
photons are being produced
and then disappearing but actually once
in a while one of the pair falls into
the black hole and then the other photon
is kind of doomed to never find its
friend ever again and has to wander the
universe forever as a real particle but
it's exactly the same physics as what's
going on now here then the question is
how do you repay the debt because now
you've created energy and now you no
longer have acceleration you no longer
have things going moving backwards and
forwards there's actually only one place
that the energy can come from which is
from the mass of the black hole because
the energy is mass times the speed of
light squared so the mass of the black
hole is a source of energy so what has
to happen bizarrely is you've got
something falling into a black hole
makes the mass of the black hole
decrease over time
and this is this process of a black hole
effectively emitting photons and in the
process of emitting photons losing mass
is this thing called hawking radiation
and why black holes eventually have left
to their own devices will evaporate i
gather from that that all black holes
are doomed to evaporate away because
they can't help this thing happening at
their event horizon but there's so
that's certainly true but there are two
things to bear in mind firstly it's an
incredibly slow process which means that
actually you know black holes which form
very early in the universe unless
they're really low mass black holes
won't reach that stage even today and
the other thing is that actually that's
how a black hole loses mass but of
course a black hole can always gain mass
just by stuff falling into it and almost
certainly most black holes in the
universe there's more stuff falling in
that than they're actually losing by
this evaporation process so actually
even though the process is always there
probably most black holes are actually
putting on weight rather than losing it
i mean it's never been detected directly
so in that sense it's just a theory but
actually it's a pretty solid theory in
the sense that all the physics that goes
into it is we're reasonably comfortable
with there's something slightly
uncomfortable about this whole area of
physics because you're combining
gravitation with quantum mechanics so
you've got the gravity of the black hole
you've got the quantum mechanics of
these virtual particles and there is
it's well known that there's a missing
piece of physics that we don't really
understand how to put quantum mechanics
and gravity together
but from the limited understanding we do
have it looks like this is a pretty
solid result that actually black holes
will indeed evaporate by this process
and we've got a little detector here so
in you know in simple terms all you're
doing is you're firing some light out
there it bounces back
and gets detected and then you've got a
little thing that says okay whenever i
detect some light i'll send another
pulse up